it's working hi first of all yeah I know
it's a mess here but I'm working on it
in steps and you might not be able to
see those steps but trust me they're
they're like no it's gonna make some
reference to being blind and how you
can't see steps but they're there when
you really look okay let's move on it's
Superman okay okay I'm gonna start with
um postcards for instance this one which
is hilarious look at that that girl is
taking her destiny in her own hands
uh who is this um this is from Amanda
Amanda Duncan from Fort Mitchell
Kentucky whoa cool I felt you would
appreciate this postcard from Pride and
Prejudice and Zombies oh I see I didn't
read that book Michelle's been told me
to read that book because she really
likes it and I haven't read it but I
trust it's good um keep on being
hilarious make me smile I hope you
enjoyed your trip to the Grand Canyon
yay
I did enjoy it thank you so introduced
postcard this is awesome did you read
the book did you enjoy that book I
haven't even read of Pride and Prejudice
so I am beat and I'm a butt okay and
this is a postcard of Montreal I've been
to Montreal only for a day and I went to
like a bar on the main strip of bars in
Montreal I don't know what street that
was this is not a good story cool story
bro okay so this is from sherry gee
maybe went to gee maybe it's an L a man
said oh you know I'm gonna say G from
Montreal dear grace I'm writing this to
you because I can't decide whom I should
write to and the only stranger who I can
think of is you yeah I'm a stranger you
can trust sort of um let's see my
favorite video from Daily Grace is the
one where you taught us how to listen to
Lady Gaga's edge of glory yay I'm glad
for that I will read the rest of this
but if I get into reading all of the
postcards and letters all the way
through this will be a very long video
um but thank you so much
house Montero do you enjoy it you guys
can drink there when you're 18 that's
fun which means that you all probably
drink there when you're 14
what no I should give you credit okay
what else to be done another any other
postcards oh here's one
ooh what is it an even look Ontario cat
only a little Canadian is there coming
out of the woodwork right now this is
from Sarah mcfar me your last name looks
crazy MacFarlane sorry I'm not reading
this very well
hi grace just started watching your
videos you're hilarious
cheers me up every day I look forward to
future creases keep it up you keep it up
thank you so much for this postcard this
place that you live in Ontario looks
nice um there's a statue this looks like
this is a funny statue looks like a mom
and dad fighting over a child so if
that's symbolic of what happens in
Ontario I probably won't go visit but
thank you for this that's very sweet
okay let's get it two letters grace
that's my name this is from Gabby with
an exclamation of yes there's an address
Gabby thank you Gabby from Nashville
Tennessee sorry I bet it ruined us back
for maybe everyone that you know from
Tennessee and so they don't do that
naturally nothing like a I'm gonna try
and do your accent wait her nose I don't
know you but I'd like to
that wasn't maybe a rambling ooh what is
this what is this huh
what okay this is this Thank You Gabby
is this you it makes my eyes water
not out of crying just out of like I'm
gonna have a nightmare about this Thank
You Gabby that's really sweet of you
I don't know I'm confused so I will
repress it and move on who's next
this is from Tweety in Elk Grove Village
Illinois I feel like that's not your
real name but maybe it isn't it so more
power to your parents are being bold
when they first you whoa oh my gosh
Oh an envelope that means they want me
to mail something what what hello grace
from Oak Grove Illinois I love you on G
for always funny and beautiful you need
to get some movie or TV roles working on
trying you're one of the funniest people
I've seen in a while Broadway Hollywood
stay great and yes you need more photos
of yourself
oh so you jacked Wheaties your name and
you sent me this little picture of me
and lederhosen and I love photos of
myself
thank you so much that's very sweet of
you Jeff Tweedy
I'm glad the tweet is your last name
you're not your first name actually
thinking about it Oh
instantly distracted look at this
postcard this is from today you know
yeah Deena from Sydney Australia this is
amazing
Thank You Deena I like sending postcards
to people so I decided to send one to
you I got this one in Japan and I've
been waiting for just the right person
to send it to this never look would I
have guessed that you got this in Japan
that might be the last place I would
guess but this is awesome
thank you so much how's Australia is it
awesome oh cool yeah whoa neat ooh this
is from Christina Martinez from
Lafayette California Highway
I will never burn to not show your
addresses so I really apologize but like
breaking down each other's addresses
maybe I don't know yeah but I'd like to
it's doing it again grace what's up
[ __ ]
look at this oh cool penmanship I'm
sitting in my history class watching the
Graduate they hold one oh the new one
right did they make a remake of it cuz I
think I've seen the old one I never see
movies and I think I've seen the old
version of the Graduate I started
watching your videos a few months ago
and I can spend hours watching them I'm
dying to try from Fetty brownies but my
mom hates when I bake for no reason your
mom sounds like not a fun
I think you should try it but also obey
your mom's rules I'm conflicted thank
you for this letter apparently you
weren't really watching they graduate
because you were writing this letter so
thank you that's very sweet of you Eric
penslar in Southaven mi Michigan is it
no man this M because I always remember
mein spelled me and I thought that that
was like ah another picture maybe but
you made it into a guard dear grace hi
sincerely ugh you make like this very
nice
this is nice paper oh you did thank you
for this this is very nice it's also
very that's inception but not inception
this is just me looking at me weird
mrs. vanity right now thank you for this
this is very sweet of you
I was good weird looking at my own face
from Oh Oh No
Oh volley Jimin Jimin Asst New York New
York sorry I can't pronounce your name
I'm not gonna Oh something lips just
fell out of this a lip pen I like it
already
Cherry's life's a bowl of cherries I
don't know why why because of nice
people like you okay I don't like the
bowl of cherries because of nice people
like you is that I saying I mean ah
thank you that's very sweet I like the
colors on this makes me happy I'm not
colorblind
Thanks going you're true you're true me
and Bailey's and that we equal heart we
will love um hello brace I've been
watching your videos for months now and
you were just brilliant I my IQs not
that great but thank you that's raised
to me
I hope my penmanship is good enough for
you to read it is it's very nice it's
got character
this envelope there's a little kiss pin
then I hope you wear ah you're so mean
he sincerely Oh smiley I'm smiling I'm
so bad at pronouncing names you
thank you for making me laugh in the
morning thank you for sending this car
that is so awesome of you is very sweet
and I like that
and I showed your address again but I
like the envelope super cute this is
tiger shark from Maryland Oh No tiger
shark someone got creative with the name
you're not a tiger oh my gosh dear grace
I realize you're busy with your various
projects so I don't know if you had a
chance to read all the poems I posted
off you posted poems on My Damn Channel
oh my gosh and you get ah you made a
book you made a book of a tale of a girl
named grace that hates cats and sharks
and the tiger shark that seeks justice
huh and that's us oh this is me and you
have all these poems you know my mom's a
poet did you know that yeah my mom who's
been in the video she's not she writes
poems she does the poems stuff the
poetry this is amazing thank you so much
for this this is so cool it's so
creative from Gus
aka tiger shark thank you so much that's
so so nice I will read these later mmm
you guys are sending some good stuff
today
Nicholas coutny whoo like a coat with an
Y at the end of it
that's cool what nationality was that
name kaddish kodesh I ruined it
let's see what it is [ __ ] oh its
height dear grace Helbig you are so
formal use my first and last name I
watched you talk of the show daily and
the day I saw you on the show I thought
my lungs were gonna shrivel up and
vanish and my face would become stuck
with a smile forever from laughing so
hard that would have been a lot of money
for your medical insurance I just
recently started watching your videos on
YouTube and I reluctantly made fried
salad just like you it was really good
but let me say it didn't go well for my
toilet laughs laughs laughs truth in
comedy I had decent very um two thumbs
up against my face with a smile oh you
were in volume awesome you are awesome
Nicolas
thank you so much for this letter that
was very very sweet of you and thank you
for watching attack of the show and
enjoying it and then using it as a
catalyst to watch the YouTube videos
very cool of you thank you so much your
penmanship very oh you're from
Philadelphia that's fun I know that
place
oh my gosh happy 26th grow we peers live
it up ah this is so nice from Charlene
Munoz from Hayward California Thank You
already this is cool oh and I ripped it
in half I wrecked it sorry I ruined it
there's a lot of text whoa is this you
is that you down there you look like
you're fun you look like super fun um
I'm interesting as [ __ ] or give me a
shout-out huh you're super modest I
would make my year whoa I do grace you
deserve your name tree written in
cursive you wrote it so cool look at
that that is awesome
my name is Charlene and I'm brand
spankin new fan why the hell has it
taken me so long to discover you oh I
don't know I'm still so upset about it
I'm pretty sure I have a girl crush on
you okay you go girl I would probably do
some crazy ass [ __ ] to spend a day with
you oh wait that sounds a bit on the
stalker side no man there's very nice
thank you um this is very nice I'm not
gonna read it all on camera because do
you no but thank you I will read this
later this is awesome thank you so much
for writing this and your penmanship is
beautiful and this is sweet of you thank
you okay what do we got
uh oh no Charlotte wait you sent me two
letters
you said Charlene mu knows again take
two you send another letter oh my gosh
oh my gosh
I still feel me yes Sam oh oh wait um
are you in class with M my thoughts have
stopped you crazy
and I [ __ ] love it keep making videos
my health depends on it okay thanks bye
sure you want this and he Eric you Mona
the same
thing class school did you how did you
what you made these together my you made
my brain stops functioning thank you
that's really awesome of you okay mo
nica ash tree from Toronto Ontario
Canada and we know what happens in
Ontario people good statues of parents
fighting over a child you guys fun up
there
c-congratulations yeah I put it together
how wonderful for you firstly
congratulations a wing winning king of
the web that's so nice and you drew me
with a crown yeah and you drew Oaks hugs
but I only have one pair compared to you
like three or something yeah that's good
don't have one pair I have I have two
three and I can't not and I try not to
so often and I can't um how does it feel
to be king you fool some losing but
awesomer let's see I get so excited
about these sorry from talking about
fast I hope you are having a good day
Monica Thank You Monica I will read the
rest of it I just skip to the bottom but
thank you this is so nice of you and you
drugs very well so well did it make
someone a fourth pair I won't but you
know what green envelope woo from Megan
Whitman from Marvel Missouri mo misery I
also thought that said Margaritaville
that's where my brain goes so you guys
know that I can't now Bennett margaritas
are delicious when you're all a beige
you should try one but a good one the
gal pal what what is this thing a
natural artist with a flair for interior
design and fashion enjoys hanging out
with girls reading here is just some
time mistake him for a French exchange
and has a taste for feather boas Oh
there's things it's your birthday be
happy be gay be anything but French oh
thank you this card I didn't know where
I was gonna go but I'm glad I went there
that's awesome
what is this a picture of huh you sent
me a picture of a of a bunny typing on a
computer with its feet of course you did
that's awesome of you and what is this
I saw this in thought of you
Baileys Irish cream chocolate truffles
recipe huh I might have to make this on
a Thursday video thank you that's
awesome Megan tell your mommy said
thanks she made a great decision to
raise you huh that's so nice of you I'll
read the rest of this car but thank you
so much this card is hilarious and I
want to buy these for other people that
I know thank you that's very nice okay
here's one that feels like it's got
something in it I just got some like
Lisa Frank stickers ooh and it's from
Melissa and Cline oh and you have your
own monogram envelope stickers I used to
have those it made me feel like I was an
adult when I was young my mom I'm gonna
use scissors to open this I'm not gonna
use any of the 17,000 envelope opener so
you guys sorry whoa what is this is this
a Halloween
it's a Halloween pin those are things
otherwise known as pumpkins and and you
sent me so many stickers oh my gosh
thank you these are Lisa Frank stickers
I got it right
I know me Lisa Frank there's one thing I
know in the world it's my way around a
bottle of vodka and makes it whoa I
think I just broke your letter hey grace
it's about valid July's from tumblr yay
when I saw that you liked my two posts
of the gifts I mean everywhere I almost
fell on my chair it's so exciting
yes you're so awesome in every way and I
love love love your videos my husband
John is the US Army soldier and it's
deployed right now please keep your
soldiers and thoughts and hopes they
might come and eat sorry I'm not reading
keep our soldiers in your thoughts in
hopes they come home safely you got a
girl thanks for making me smile when I'm
down happy Halloween hope you enjoy the
stickers must' thank you so much Melissa
I'm so sorry that your husband's
overseas right now but we're thinking
about I'm he's doing something really
cool so thank you for that letter that
was so kind of you and oh it broke oh it
was a cat and it broke I'm sorry I'm so
sorry but I get the picture
but it's just mail sometimes says that
but the the oh is this supposed to spell
boo oh the cat was the bee that's all
right
thank you go it's the thought that
counts it really is okay what is this
this is from Ana MS and Kaitlyn w from
Oh
Nana emo British Columbia Canada no
thank you
what is this
show us your spooky what huh you send me
photos of you guys be crazy what are you
making you're making sweet babies and
you're making uh oh let me guess look
not having fun waiting I know that game
oh oh this says it on the back oh I'm
I'm being bad at doing this off to go
back through grace where Anna and
Kaitlyn in today we're cooking sweet we
need spaghetti which sandwiches I'm
fried salad we'll keep you posted it
went really well
yay I'll go through these like a
slideshow later but thank you girls I'm
glad you have fun and make sure the
photos bring cool stuff that photos of
people that I don't know in real life
okay this is from we're almost there
guys
dad see from Trenton South Carolina
there's also a treatment in New Jersey
the Capitol impact and also totally
crime ridden open inside an envelope
with stickers hey grace neat videos hope
you have an awesome day but this letter
is more than just getting to tell you
how awesome you are the friend girl who
I don't really get to speak to much
anymore we barely get to text now or any
other of that crazy internet talking
jazz we used to be much closer and I
really liked her a lot
even though she'll never feel like that
for me but I think she's been really
happy without me so I can still be happy
for I do miss her though so I'm ready to
see if you can help make her feel
special by wishing her a happy birthday
which is on October 27th her name
k CR k CR uh this is this letter got me
sad oh I would I hope that you had a
good birthday a couple weeks ago I'm
sorry and open this letter sooner but
this is really sweet from what's - see
dusty wants to talk to you uh what is
this I don't know if this is what this
is confusing and vigorous asexually
stickers oh this is what the stickers
are wrapped in yay smiley faces alright
I feel like you might need the smiley
face more than I do
what is and then you said this card huh
excuse me but I need to ask you
something
ah what it's a cat and jeans could it
possibly be what the [ __ ] you're doing
in those jeans
has it been hard to stay adorable for
all these years
oh okay see thank you so much I'm
confused as to % what but thank you this
is really very sweet of you ok wait
Casey sent this and then dad sent the
letter about me wishing Casey happy
birthday huh is how it just happened
if so awesome I hope that you guys talk
more I'm I'm slightly confused but I'm
so excited that something has happened
oh no no um let's see Sarah Wendler from
University Place Washington was it like
to constantly be in school what grace
facts history according to Daily Grace
you made oh my gosh
she made a book of all the historical
facts and they are categorized by food
entertainment beverages drugs oh my gosh
you're crazy
awesome thank you so much this with a
duck on it holy crap holy grace it's
just a rough draft probably ready for
publishing soon though you're absolutely
layers and I love watching you sweet
fits and thanks for that stay golden
Ponyboy
Sarah Wendler this is some awesome
you so much for this that's amazing that
you did that
totally quietly Wow okay this is from
Laura Crumpler from Colonial Heights
Virginia and it sounds like something
either shaky or something broke inside I
don't know oh my gosh oh my gosh what is
this marios noodles
oh I hope it has drugs in it oh and OH
googly-eye keychains and wine I'm a
lizard why not
this is awesome oh can you see the
googly eye look at those look at those
this is crazy
spider-man candy sticks
oh whoa and an array said it's a toad
toad eraser okay and what is this happy
Halloween have a little bit frightful
all around delightful wonderful
Halloween hey grace I love your YouTube
videos and I think you are the coolest
chick around I hope you have a wonderful
Halloween and that you enjoy the little
treats I send lots of love Laura thank
you Laura
uh thank you for this candy I might eat
it and I also might not eat it but thank
you so much first week okay no room for
last final thanks guys we're almost a
home stretch okay
oh my gosh okay I don't know what to do
first I'll do you this white paper okay
this is from Chantal in Windsor Ontario
Canada and guys what have we learned
about Ontario Canada a lot more than you
thought you're gonna learn in this video
oh my goodness what is this this is
grace Helbig grace Helbig please I just
got my name what is that exclamation
oh he you made this oh my you may owe my
shuttle
what the crap did you oh my gosh
oh you kind of return to sender I'm glad
you got its impact because that is
amazing
thank you so much that's too much thank
you so much oh okay
let's keep going this is from Denzel in
perséphone New Jersey I know that place
I know Parsippany okay I don't wanna
hurt whatever is in here but I want to
get it out of this place okay you
promise to never hurt yourself crazy oh
my gosh Oh Oh everyone down gunfire oh
give you to me bracelets are these
bracelets I think these are bracelets I
think they are know that did you get I
should read the letters instead of just
gifting and wandering the letter hello
grace how are you I'm a big fan of your
show a hearty congratulations for
winning king of the web my name is
Denzel I'm from percept New Jersey
here's a gift from me as a token of my
appreciation hope you like to my mom
picked it out since I'm not good with
gifts ah this is amazing this is so
sweet thank you so much I think these
are bracelets they're awesome they're so
pretty thank you then though that is too
nice of you oh my gosh I I don't know
what to say to these things these are so
nice oh you're getting sentimental
- this this is from thank you very much
for those prices this is from who what
does it say
Marcus latina/o from the UK oh my
goodness is from the UK
oh whatever
oh how about never break whatever is
inside of here and I hope it's not um
what is um what is this I'm confused
i has confusion get open to me what what
are you wondering what this is - I hope
so something where did you go
wait is this are these just supposed to
hold this is just posted I can't form
sentences and I don't know what's going
on no no no are you kidding me are you
grace please accept this as a token of
my appreciation as you have very
entertaining this rendition of yourself
encapsulate all of your favorite things
the season of fall extra-large wineglass
Modern Art 60 Friday nudity and the tree
silhouette thank you Marcus Lowe tigner
Yakko dot uk' this is on it I think I'm
taken okay but this is amazing thank you
so much this is oh my gosh I don't even
know what to say thank you that is so
nice of you and thank everyone for
everything that they said you guys are
so so nice and I don't know what else to
say so I'm just gonna go but thank you
guys so much this is oh this just made
my night haha bye